The holidays are here in full swing, which
gives you two options: spend your evenings
with family and loved ones, or hide away from
those weird relatives and catch up on all
of Netflix's newest TV shows and movies.
This December, you can definitely expect plenty
of holiday themed movies to hit the service,
but that's not all.
Here's a breakdown of everything you'd be
crazy to miss on Netflix in December 2017,
starting with the Netflix originals.
Dark: Season 1
When two kids go missing in a small German
town, their families are plunged into a mystery
that goes back decades.
That's the premise for Dark, a German-language
Netflix original series.
The morose atmosphere and flat color palette
showcased in the trailer evoke immediate comparisons
to Stranger Things, although we're hoping
the 10-episode first season goes in a new
direction and delivers something wholly original.
Dark premieres on December 1st.
Easy: Season 2
An all-star cast is slated to appear in the
second season of Netflix's anthology series,
Easy.
Marc Maron, Dave Franco, and Aubrey Plaza
are just a few of the names showing up in
the new season, and series creator Joe Swanberg
is again taking over writing and directing
duties for each of the second season's eight
episodes.
The entire season premieres on December 1st.
My Happy Family
Sundance darling My Happy Family is getting
a Netflix-exclusive release on the first of
the month.
The Georgian film starts with three generations
of a tight-knit family living in a single
home, only for their lives to be flipped upside
down when 52-year-old Manara makes a shocking
announcement: she's moving out.
Tender and emotional, My Happy Family paints
a subtle portrait of what it means to leave
everything you know, and the struggle to cope
with the fact that your happy family is really
anything but.
Voyeur
True crime has never been so intimate.
This Netflix original documentary is an adaptation
of 2016's The Voyeur's Motel, a nonfiction
account centered on Gerald Foos, a motel owner
who installed special grates in his motel's
rooms that would allow him to spy on his guests
without their knowledge.
The book was written by journalist Gay Talese,
who also stars in the documentary.
The film rights were actually purchased by
Steven Spielberg in 2016, but plans for his
feature film were shelved following news that
Netflix was producing a documentary on the
subject.
Take a peep when Voyeur drops on December
1st.
Craig Ferguson: Tickle Fight
Longtime Late Late Show host Craig Ferguson
is landing on Netflix with an all-new comedy
stand-up special.
This will mark Ferguson's second special on
the streaming service, following his 2013
special Craig Ferguson: I'm Here to Help.
If Tickle Fight takes the same cues as his
prior special, it's bound to be hilarious,
timely, and completely irreverent.
"When a smart woman wants to stay married
to a guy after the wedding she fattens him
up a little bit, not too much!
Just enough to slow the 'f----- down in case
he gets any ideas."
Look for it on December 5th.
El Camino Christmas
When five people are taken hostage in a liquor
store on Christmas Eve, the holidays quickly
turn into a nightmare.
El Camino Christmas stars Tim Allen, Dax Shepard,
Jessica Alba, and Vincent D'Onofrio in a comedic
crime story about one man's search for his
father that goes horribly wrong.
The movie's based on a script by Ted Melfi,
who wrote and directed the Oscar-nominated
Hidden Figures as well as St. Vincent.
Check it out on December 8th.
The Crown: Season 2
Netflix's award-winning historical drama The
Crown is gearing up for Season 2, continuing
the story of a young Queen Elizabeth The Second,
her marriage to Prince Philip, and her struggles
to maintain order in a constantly changing
world scarred by war.
The second season will see the return of the
main cast, along with the addition of Dexter's
Michael C. Hall in the role of John F. Kennedy.
The wait is over on December 8th.
Judd Apatow: The Return
Despite being the man behind the camera on
countless smash hit comedies—including The
40-Year-Old-Virgin, Knocked Up, and Trainwreck—you
don't often get a chance to see Judd Apatow
in front of the camera.
That's all changing with Judd Apatow: The
Return, a stand-up special that sees Apatow
step on the stage for the first time in over
25 years.
Look for it on December 12.
Erased: Season 1
Based on the manga of the same name, Erased
is an all-new live-action show about a man
who discovers that he has the ability to travel
back in time to prevent past tragedies from
happening.
This will mark the third adaption of the manga,
the previous two being an anime series that
premiered in January 2016 and a live-action
film that screened in Japan in March 2016.
Get ready for an all-new telling of the story
when Erased: Season 1 drops on December 15th.
The Ranch: Part 4
The Ashton Kutcher-led sitcom The Ranch has
been an audience favorite since its 2016 premiere,
although critics haven't been particularly
kind to the show.
The story centers on Colt Bennett, a football
player who couldn't cut it in the big time,
so he's forced to move back to the family
ranch in Colorado.
As they did with the latest season of Fuller
House, Netflix released each season of The
Ranch broken up into two parts.
Part 4, which is the second part of Season
2, hits Netflix on December 15th.
Ultimate Beastmaster: Season 2
Who doesn't love watching contestants bash
their way through a seemingly impossible obstacle
course?
In the spirit of Ninja Warrior, Ultimate Beastmaster
pits elite athletes against the clock as they
struggle to make it past a series of gruelling
physical challenges.
Season 2 arrives on December 15th, so sit
back and live vicariously through the pain
of others.
The American way.
Wormwood
The first teaser for Netflix's hotly anticipated
show Wormwood dropped way back in August,
and the hype has only grown since then.
Part fiction and part documentary, the show
dives into the dark history of the CIA's infamous
MK Ultra experiments, focusing specifically
on one scientist who was involved in the secretive
operation.
From Oscar-winning director Errol Morris,
Wormwood promises a paranoia-fueled journey
into the dark heart of government conspiracy.
Settle in for the six-part miniseries on December
15th.
Hello, My Twenties!: Season 2
Also known as Age of Youth in its origin country
of South Korea, this comedy-drama series follows
five college-age girls from different walks
of life who live in the same house.
If you haven't seen the first season yet,
now would be a good time to go back and watch
it, because Season 2 arrives on December 18th.
Russell Howard: Recalibrate
British comedian Russell Howard has been selling
out shows across the UK, and now he's slated
to star in a Netflix-exclusive stand-up special,
Russel Howard: Recalibrate.
Queue up the laughs on December 19th.
The Indian Detective: Season 1
Starring Russell Peters, Christina Cole, and
William Shatner, The Indian Detective is a
Canadian crime comedy about a Toronto cop
who gets drawn into a murder investigation
while visiting his family in India.
The first season consists of four episodes,
all of which are slated to arrive on Netflix
on December 19th.
La Casa de Papel: Season 1
This heist thriller made waves with its Spanish
television premiere, and now Netflix is rolling
it out to international audiences on December
20th.
The title translates to "The House of Paper,"
and the story follows eight bank robbers planning
to pull off the biggest heist Spain has ever
seen.
If you don't mind the subtitles, you can binge
the entire first season when La Casa de Papel
drops later this month.
Peaky Blinders: Season 4
Ever since its 2013 premiere, Peaky Blinders
has steadily gained more and more attention,
with critics praising the show's characters,
acting, and story, among many other elements
that come together to make this powerful drama
as effective as it is.
"I want you to be alive after your entire
family is passed."
Whether you've been waiting eagerly for Season
4 or are just now starting the entire series,
mark your calendar for December 21st and get
ready for the brand new season.
Bright
Written by Max Landis and directed by David
Ayer, Bright is a Netflix original film starring
Will Smith as Daryl Ward, an LAPD officer
who has to team up with an Orc to stop an
evil force threatening to destroy the world.
Equal parts crime thriller and fantasy, Bright
promises a take on the buddy cop trope that'll
definitely be unique, if nothing else.
Look for it on December 22nd.
Fuller House: Season 3, New Episodes
Ever since Netflix released the first part
of Season 3 of Fuller House in September,
fans have been eagerly anticipating the season's
second half.
"But… our boarding passes say we are flying
coach."
"Coach… bmmmm"
And the wait will soon be over—the final
nine episodes of Season 3 are slated for a
December 22nd release, just in time to tune
in with the whole family over the holidays.
The Toys That Made Us: Season 1
Get ready for a blast from the past with The
Toys That Made Us, Netflix's new nostalgia-driven
series that looks back on the iconic toys
of the '80s and '90s and the stories behind
them.
If you're thinking He-Man, G.I.
Joe, and Transformers, you're on the right
track.
"It's two against one."
"Wrong Boneface.
It's two agains two!"
"Moss Man fooled you, Yarrrrrr!"
The show premieres on December 22, just in
time to make you rethink your holiday wish
list.
Cable Girls: Season 2
Set in 1928, Cable Girls tells the story of
four women who get jobs at a state-of-the-art
telecom company in Madrid, focusing on their
troubled past lives and the relationships
that emerge as they finally get a new lease
on life.
Season 1 served up plenty of hard-hitting
drama, and chances are fans can expect more
of the same from the second season, which
will be available for streaming on Christmas
day.
Todd Barry: Spicy Honey
Veteran stand-up comic Todd Barry is joining
the Netflix line-up this December with Todd
Barry: Spicy Honey, a new comedy special that
promises more of Barry's signature dry style
coupled with brand-new material that fans
are sure to love.
Tune in on December 26 for all the laughs.
It's the day after Christmas.
What else are you going to do?
Travelers: Season 2
Once you're done burning through Future Man
and 11.22.63 over on Hulu, head back to Netflix
to get your time-travel fix with the Season
2 premiere of Travelers.
Created by Brad Wright, the man behind Stargate
SG-1 and Stargate: Atlantis, Travelers follows
four people hundreds of years in the future
who transport their minds back into new bodies
in the 21st century in an attempt to prevent
the dystopia that will become of our world.
Season 2 of the sci-fi drama will be released
globally on Netflix on December 26th.
Bill Nye Saves the World: Season 2: Part 1
The first season of Bill Nye Saves the World
was met with a storm of controversy.
Most people disliked the content and the political
nature of the show, while others were just
upset that Nye didn't seem to be the same
Science Guy we loved from the '90s.
"Good heavens!
It's Bill Nye the Science Guy!"
Either way, the majority of the show's audience
found something to hate, and the Season 2
announcement trailer made the unusual decision
to highlight the negative reactions to the
first season.
Because that always helps.
Love it or hate it, Bill Nye Saves the World
is returning, with the second season landing
on December 29th.
La Mante: Season 1
Originally aired in France, La Mante, or "The
Mantis," is a psychological drama about the
search for a vicious criminal who's recreating
the crimes perpetrated by The Mantis, a psychopath
who operated 20 years previously.
The police have no choice but to turn to The
Mantis for help tracking down the new murderer.
The six-episode miniseries premieres on December
29th.
Dave Chappelle: Equanimity
Netflix is ending the year with a new comedy
special from Dave Chappelle, his third to
hit Netflix in 2017.
Netflix describes Dave Chappelle: Equanimity
as a return "to his roots."
After Chappelle's long hiatus from the spotlight
and some mixed reviews on his previous Netflix
specials, we can only hope his newest outing
delivers on that promise.
Check it out when it lands on New Year's Eve.
"Do me!
Do me next."
That does it for the Netflix originals coming
out in December 2017.
Now let's look at everything else that's hitting
the streaming service.
New movies
We know, government plots and space battles
don't usually come to mind when you think
of the holidays, but Netflix is ushering in
a few action movies this month that will give
you a break from the snow and sleet.
V for Vendetta will be available on December
1, followed by Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
2 on the 5th.
"I'm Mary Poppins, yall!"
Netflix is also doubling down on classic comedy
films.
Relive the past with both original Ace Ventura
films, Hitch, Nacho Libre, and While You Were
Sleeping on December 1st.
And if those get you in the mood for family
movie night, you're in luck.
From Trolls Holiday Special, landing on December
6th, to all three films in The Santa Clause
franchise on December 12th, you won't be able
to escape the festivities this year.
Even if you try.
Of course, the holidays aren't all about love
and family—sometimes you need a dose of
betrayal and revenge, just to round things
out.
On December 1st, Netflix is adding drama classics
like 8 Mile and Full Metal Jacket to their
lineup, followed by Nicolas Winding Refn's
Pusher on December 27.
In the thriller genre, Netflix is adding 2003's
Dreamcatcher, starring Tom Jane.
Then, on December 23, tune in for Creep 2,
the sequel to the 2014 underground hit.
Mark Duplass returns as everyone's favorite
psycho, with Patrick Bryce back in the director's
chair.
Finally, the documentary line-up is definitely
cause for excitement, with the addition Planet
Earth II, the 2016 follow-up to BBC's award-winning
2006 nature series.
If you're a fan of nature docs, get ready
to experience the world like you've never
seen it before—again—on December 25th.
Other documentaries to watch this month include
The Farthest: Voyager in Space, a PBS production
about the Voyager probes.
Check it out on December 1st, and then look
for Discovering Bigfoot and Freeway: Crack
in the System on December 15th.
New Television
You'll find plenty of shows to binge on outside
of the Netflix originals lineup.
Highlights this December include The Magicians:
Season 2 on December 11th, Halt and Catch
Fire: Season 4 on December 14th, and Reggie
Yates Outside Man on the 15th.
If you're into cooking shows, Netflix has
you covered there as well, with Chef & My
Fridge dropping on December 1st and Season
1 of Ainsley Eats the Streets on December
14th.
No matter what you're looking for, there's
bound to be a show for you.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!